these Israeli reservists are adding
their names to a declaration that says
they'll no longer report for active duty
in protest against the government's
proposed judicial changes
they're among a growing number of Pilots
soldiers and Intelligence Officers who
say they're acting on principle I came
here today to sign to convey the message
that I will not serve the dictator I
will not serve in a dictatorship
I'm here to say that my kids won't grow
up in a dictatorship in a place that
abolishes the basic human rights of
equality
military service is compulsory for most
Jewish men and women above the age of 18
and many volunteer for reserve duty well
into their 40s reservists reinforced the
regular army navy and Air Force in an
emergency Israel can order its entire
Reserve Force numbering more than four
hundred thousand to report for Duty
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu says
the government will not tolerate
insubordination
the refusal to serve puts the security
of all Israeli citizens at risk the
government will not accept refusal the
government will act against it and will
take all necessary steps to ensure our
security and our future
hundreds of Israeli Reserve Pilots first
joined the demonstrations against the
government in March by refusing to
report for Duty last week 400 more
announced similar action alongside air
traffic controllers and drone operators
commentators say it's significant
because the air force is largely made up
of the Israeli Elite the protests of of
their army offices but mainly the pilots
is almost a game changer and mind might
stop the legislation it's not only that
they are pilots but usually they come
from the well-off social classes
from the right places from the right
ethnic origin
and they are quite powerful
protest against the government's plans
to change the legal system show no signs
of slowing down Israel's Army Chief has
warned Netanyahu his proposed changes
could affect the Readiness of the army
Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera
it's been 100 days since fighting first